Repeatedly listening to, sort
of, the same material is creating
connections, which is beneficial.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and today,
I want to talk about why repetition
is so important in language learning.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you're listening to Apple Podcast
or Spotify, please leave a review.
So, you know that I'm a
proponent proponent of compelling
input, comprehensible input.
Uh, I'm very much a supporter
of, uh, Stephen Krashen's theory
of language acquisition, but
there are some issues with that.
And some, some of my experience,
which suggests that it's a
little bit sort of more complex.
First of all, obviously when you
start in a language, whatever you're
listening to is not comprehensible.
So you can't begin with
comprehensible input.
You'll begin with input, which is not
comprehensible, but which gradually
becomes more and more comprehensible.
Uh, however, uh, if you have access
to the text, so you can look up
words, then you have a chance.
And if you can use LingQ for example,
and you can review the words, then
you have a chance, or even if you're
using Teach Yourself or some other
starter book you can gradually get to
where material that is initially not
comprehensible becomes comprehensible.
In order for the material to be
comprehensible, or you have for you
to have a chance to make that material
comprehensible, uh, you have to have
stuff that's not that interesting.
Uh, it's not like tremendously
compelling on its own.
Uh, it's material that's somewhat
simplified because it just,
you need to start in somewhere.
Now with our mini stories at LingQ
we start into everyday situations.
We start, we don't start
in with hello, how are you?
Uh, my name is...
uh, but nevertheless it is simplified
compared to, uh, reading, you know, the
equivalent of Shakespeare or something.
So compelling?
Yes.
Eventually, in the long run.
Because in the long run, we have
to accumulate so many words.
We have to engage through
reading and listening.
We have to engage with
genuinely compelling input,
but we have to get there.
And even when we are engaged with
genuinely compelling input, there are
things that we aren't going to notice.
And that's where repetition comes in.
And I remember it's got to be up 20
odd years ago, uh, I met a recent
immigrant to Canada from China who
had been in Canada for like a year
and he spoke English almost without
an accent, and not many Chinese people
manage to do that for whatever reason,
which I won't get into now, but he did.
And what he said was that he had
this limited material that he
listened to a thousand times,
the same material over and over.
Um, I know that in my own case
for Chinese, I listened to the
same material many, many times.
Another...
in fact, I have over the years developed
this habit of repetitively listening
to a limited amount of content.
I do this with mini stories,
Persian, Arabic, Greek,
whatever I've been learning.
If I look up my statistics on
LingQ, I'll see that I've listened
to these stories 30, 40 times.
I don't listen to them
all at the same time.
I don't listen to the same
story, 30 times in a row.
Because the thing about repetition is
we start to lose, you know, the brain...
I always say this, the brain likes some
novelty, so that's, you've got to move on.
So typically what I do is I listen
to lesson one or story 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
back to one or I, I sort of shuffle
them in my, you know, uh, playlist,
but in the end, I'll have listened
to them many, many, many times.
So what I find is that listening
repetitively to a limited amount of
material has a number of benefits.
Now I am no neuroscientist, but I
know that, you know, neurons that fire
together, they form a, a connection.
Can't remember the, there was some kind
of a description of that, that you need
to get these synapses, these neurons to
be firing together repeatedly in order
to create these new neural connections,
uh, which you need for language.
So without knowing the sort of
neuroscience behind it all, I'm quite
convinced that repeatedly listening to
sort of the same material is creating
connections, which is beneficial.
Beneficial, not...
not only for your pronunciation, because
as we know from immigrants who live in,
say an English speaking country or French
Quebec, French speaking environment
say, and live 20 years and operate in
English all the time and yet their, their
pronunciation never improves, but they
are exposed to a lot of the language.
However, I believe if those same
people had the patience that this
immigrant had 20 years ago to listen
to a limited amount of content over
and over and over again, that that
might improve their pronunciation.
Certainly I find that my
ability to pronounce something
in a language is much better.
Uh, three months after, you know, I have
been listening to this repeated content,
these mini stories over and over again.
It's doing something that I'm not
really conscious of, but is helping
me to pronounce the language.
I recently did a video in
Persian and I had compliments,
at least on my pronunciation.
I have trouble.
And I was obviously searching for words,
but my pronunciation isn't bad, partly
because I've learned many languages
so probably my brain is a little more
flexible, but I also think it's because
I have been listening to these same
mini stories over and over and over.
The other advantage of, there are a number
of advantages, of sort of repeatedly
listening to a limited range of content.
It's easy to do.
You can focus in, focus out.
It's something that I
can do while exercising.
Uh, I don't need to be concentrating
and yet still it's working on my brain
and it's not only the pronunciation
that is kind of being grooved in
there, it's also a certain structure.
Uh, so that all of a sudden these
phrases or structures come out because
I have listened to them over and over
again, while exercising, while doing
the dishes, even while being in the,
you know, driving the car and so forth.
So, uh, repetitive listening, uh, is,
is not compelling input necessarily
by the time you're on, you're
listening to it for the 30th time.
It's not compelling, but even the
30th time there are things there
that I notice, there are phrases
that I notice, there are changes in
the form of the verb that I notice.
It might be an issue of intonation
and the language that I notice so
that there are, you know, aspects of
the language that are subconsciously
being grooved in my brain, because
these synapses are firing all the time.
Then pardon me, I'm not a
neuroscience, I'm assuming.
Uh, and also.
Uh, there are things that we
notice, so that both subconsciously
and consciously with a sort of a
limited sampling, we are gaining
greater confidence in the language.
And I think repetitive listening
to things like the mini stories
is great preparation for speaking.
Uh, whereas, you know, obviously
exploring new stuff more interesting, more
compelling stuff, especially if we follow
it up with reading is going to expand
our vocabulary, our range of vocabulary.
But in terms of getting a better handle
on the basic structures of the language
and the pronunciation of the language,
these call them basics, which I always
feel can't be learned upfront, but which
can be learned later on that these basics
are often best acquired through having
a program of repeated listening to a
limited range of material and blending
that in with the sort of more, you know,
uh, extensive reading and listening.
Uh, listening to more compelling material
reading or compelling material, which
is also of course very important,
but even at a fairly advanced level
in the language, I find that this
repeated listening to a limited
range of relatively simple material.
And particularly if it's a voice
that we like, uh, even if the content
is not compelling, can be very,
very helpful in strengthening our
confidence in using the language.
So there you have a why repetition
is important in language learning.
Bye for now.